well dearest counter-strike stands
it happened cs go's 11th operation rip
tide
is upon us
and i don't care that nades are
droppable i don't
i don't care about the deagle nerf i
don't care about the fact that the
silencer is about to strike back and i
don't care about the dust 2 changes
i don't care about shorter matches i
don't care about private hues the gamma
glocks or the riot shield they threw
into hostage maps
i don't care about any of it because
ladies and gentlemen after years of
waiting we have finally been blessed
with a butterfly floor
let's
[Music]
all right before we start unboxing stuff
i gotta ask that you like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications because i have already
spent way too much money trying to pull
a bfk lore
and would really appreciate your help in
trying to recoup some of it okay so
yesterday as heralded all day on our
twitter timelines valve did in fact drop
csgo's newest operation
riptide
it's nautical themed there's like sharks
and water and scuba steve and two
trailers
which was really funny because for some
reason it really threw simple for a
[Music]
it's
[Music]
oh my
god dude oh jesus suffice it to say
there is a ton to talk about since this
could very well be the biggest or the
very least the most significant update
that the game has seen
since like 2016
maybe ever let's start with the easy
stuff
shorter matches
mr12 mr12 who
why not mr
10
is it 10 that's how that works
valve said 16
that's per game
whatever first to nine
first to nine that's right valerante
enthusiasts cs go now provides you with
the option to cue shortened mm matches
in which your competitive skill group is
still at stake
i'm sure they'll be rough since the ct
economy isn't really built for games
that short but hey it's mm who cares
also good news you can finally run a
10-man without having to use an external
server valve have implemented what
they're calling a private queue which
will allow a group of players to use
codes and steam groups and such to run a
private match on the game's official
servers
there's also two new deathmatch modes
free for all and team vs team which will
now sit alongside the already existing
classic mode that people only cue when
they have operation challenges to do now
let's get to the good stuff gameplay
changes for starters valve finally
finally found a way to nerf the [ __ ]
deagle body shots now inflict less
damage which means that you need to be
really up close to two shot people in
the chest not close enough if you ask me
but definitely close enough that it'll
make a difference
speaking of body shots
ladies and gentlemen the era of the
silencer is once again upon us from this
day onwards the m4 a1s will now inflict
more damage to the body meaning that
while it still takes two head shots to
kill it only takes four body shots from
any range to take down an enemy in
combination with last year's price
reduction
this actually means that the a1s is very
viable i still wish that valve would
make it so that the cts could have
access to both m4s from the buy menu but
hey
it's a start they also reduced the price
of the dualies to 300
which let's be honest
doesn't mean [ __ ] my boy harry put it
best
the dualies are
quite simply trash at any price unless
you're keto play for nib or wear actual
driving gloves outside of the server
like vinnie does anyone else just buy a
p250 please next we've got a handful of
map changes
some
more significant than others leaving
aside the expected yet much needed
alterations to ancients a site valve
made one single change to inferno where
they swapped out the gate behind sandbag
for a solid white door that makes seeing
the ratting piece of [ __ ] ct who's
sitting there much easier not that
anything shy of an entire overhaul would
save inferno from being the worst map in
the active duty pool yes it's worse than
vertigo don't at me
but could we at least have just like
done something anything to maybe spruce
it up a bit
open up tram
anything now my disdain for inferno
aside the thing that everyone is talking
about is the slight visibility tweak
from t-ramp through mid that valve made
on dust2
why
because they made it so that you can't
see mid-doors
from t-ramp
[Music]
how am i going to wallbang
now let's be honest this change was a
long long time coming finally the t's
cannot subject the cts to auto sniper
spam more importantly the cts don't have
to burn a smoke every time they want to
leave their spawn i will say though as
is
this change might actually be
too strong not only will tees have to
drop and boost and offer suicide to spot
mid doors but the box in suicide is no
longer viable what's more the ts can't
spot a lower tons rush through dark
unless valve opts to open up the ramp
angle a little bit which some people
have already illustrated it's obviously
way too early to tell whether it'll need
a tweak and if so what that tweak is but
whatever the case
this is a great change that will
categorically alter the way that dust2
is played
it's awesome and last but
certainly not least
what might just be the single greatest
gameplay change that cs go has ever seen
droppable nates yes
you heard me
droppable utility for the first time
ever players can now drop nades as if
they were weapons now the limits have
not changed mind you so it's not as if
one player can suddenly holster four
flashes or four mollies but teammates
can pool them on the ground and watch as
one person smokes like three places of
all the changes implemented in this
operation this is the only one that has
kind of divided the community everything
else has pretty much been unanimously
agreed to be
great for the growth of the game this is
the only one that is
kind of polemical grenades cannot be
dropped just like weapons is actually
very funny because
what's the point like if you don't know
smoke you just give it to your teammates
right or you just leave him
10 flashes around him in b apartments on
mirage
then you do one smoke window kitchen
from busy
and second smoke from t spawn on b and
he just take all the stand flashings and
throw it
one two three four five six seven and
two ten
jesus man
some think it's super broken and could
potentially overhaul the strategic
sophistication of cs go for the worse
since it makes info gathering
exponentially more difficult
others think that we should reserve
judgment until we've had a chance to see
it in action maybe it's because i'm a
dota player and have been watching ice
frog
my [ __ ] up for the better part of a
decade but i don't find myself reacting
all that negatively to this change like
sure you could drop all 10 flashes and b
apps like simple suggested and have one
guy just lob all of them onto site
but then no one else in the map would
have any flashes
this just allows teams to make more
sophisticated trade-offs which in my
completely non-professional opinion
could be very cool needless to say this
is a very very big change that i am in
no way comfortable making an actual
pronouncement upon
the only thing i will say is that being
able to
fake throw a flash the way you'd
previously fake throw a glock like to
bait an op shot
that could be really broken
yo i could keep flashing stuff
[Laughter]
now i don't know how valve fixed that
maybe change the physics so that utility
falls flatly to the ground or implement
some kind of glow around it for when
it's being dropped instead of properly
thrown
but
and maybe i'm overreacting i do
genuinely think this could be kind of an
issue turning away from a flying pistol
is one thing if you get fooled by that
that's on you
but turning away from an actual floating
flashbang that can just be lobbed around
corners at
infinitum that's not about game sense
that's just
like what can i do i have to turn away
from it right
oh and if that wasn't crazy enough they
added a riot shield to casual hostage
maps
it's great i love it a real throwback to
the old days all right now that we're
done with all that gameplay talk
it's time for the real [ __ ]
i'm not going to go over all the star
challenge mission stuff since it's all
pretty routine skins are awarded through
rolls which are activated by way of
stars which you can either buy or earn
through weekly challenges and then
redeem similar to last year and the year
before valve opted not to recycle any
previously released operation cosmetics
instead choosing to release four new map
themed collections the mirage 2021 the
train 2021 the vertigo 2021 and the
dust2 2021 so what are the highlights
for starters we've got this year's
resident super sick op the desert hydra
which twists unboxed like five minutes
after he woke up apparently because
i guess he's just better then there's
the dictator-esque ak known as the gold
aberesque which though definitely very
gaudy is also very clean you've also got
a fade ump and a case hardened mach 10
for good measure last but not least
we've got gamma doppler glocks
jiminy christmas are these things clean
and yes they come in all four phases as
well as emerald which twists also
unboxed because apparently he's just a
[ __ ] god check him pc and game
because that is not normal now it's
worth pointing out that as of right now
the offerings in the train collection
can actually be bought tier to tier
whereas the others are rolled in the
traditional way now it isn't clear right
now whether the collections will rotate
but if they do
it'll pretty much cap the prices of like
40 to 50
suffice it to say
this is actually incredibly important
when it comes to determining just how
valuable these operation skins will end
up being now i don't think valve intends
on rotating them since that would
essentially tank their value from the
get-go but who knows the train
collection is also the only one that
represents a non-active duty map meaning
no souvenir potential come the major and
is the only one with two coverts meaning
that you still have to roll for a gamma
doppler glock never mind an emerald so
it makes sense to keep it as the only
one that can be bought tier to tier
speaking of emeralds let us talk about
the real reason that we are all gathered
here today on this holiest of occasions
the knives riptide case is cool deagle
is nice ak's pretty sweet yadda yadda
who cares
what matters is that after eons of
waiting valve have finally blessed us
with an additional set of blades in the
gamma doppler finishes which aside from
the titular include brightwater
autotronic freehand black laminate and
what is in my opinion the all-time goat
lore
i personally own two lures an m9 and a
karambit and like many others have been
waiting to round out my collection with
a butterfly variant for as long as i can
remember the only reason i own a phase 3
butterfly is because until now the lore
didn't exist needless to say i'm
obsessed with the finish and would take
a butterfly lore over
quite literally any other knife in cs go
emerald included
which made it kind of painful to watch
the lovely talented and altogether
inemitable mr chad burchill pull the
very first stati
without really knowing what it was
[Music]
it's not the emerald one though
but it's a snap trap
yeah what the [ __ ]
all right that's all right we take that
anyway look that's about all i got for
you today since
honestly they're gonna fire me if i just
keep talking about skins for this long
but the consensus is clear operation
riptide
is [ __ ]
seriously a true unadulterated success
and i don't just mean skin wise i'm
talking in terms of like real actual
measurable gameplay improvements that
will bolster the health of cs go for
years to come
props to valve for
listening caring and implementing such
awesome changes thank you for all of
this seriously it's great and and please
for a butterfly lure i'll do anything
please
i i actually i know if you saw this leaf
tweeted like an hour ago he unboxed an
emerald glock which is going for like a
thousand dollars and he was like i'm
officially announcing my retirement from
professional valor
that's so good